in the middle of the last century
photographer Tom Palumbo worked for some
of the biggest fashion magazines in
America along with the styles of the day
he pointed his lens at everyone from
jazz legend Miles Davis to author Jack
Kerouac and a young Mia Farrow some of
these photographs went unseen for
decades but now his widow award-winning
author Patricia Bosworth has published
them in a brand-new book so this is all
Tom's old stuff yeah yeah these are
pictures of the Actors Studio ISM
Patricia Bosworth found her late
husband's photographs in boxes scattered
throughout their loft in New York's
Hell's Kitchen and these oh these are
some of Tom's cameras a Hasselblad and
I've saved them all and Patricia what's
this this is was the light that he used
at Vogue and bizarre it was a light that
simulated daylight in the 50s and 60s
first for Harper's Bazaar then for Vogue
Tom Palumbo helped revolutionize fashion
photography I went through literally
thousands and thousands of prints that
were stashed away in these boxes was he
pretty good archivist did he keep no he
was a terrible artist I'm still
archiving when you go around here you'll
see Palumbo had long talked about making
a book but in 2008 a rare disease took
him before he could get started so you
decided to do it in the end in the end I
did I was I was grieving after he died
you know I loved him very much
I I started looking at these pictures
and they brought back these gorgeous
memories Bosworth a best-selling author
of biographies of Montgomery Clift Jane
Fonda and photographer Diane Arbus began
working on her late husband's story Tom
Palumbo dreamer with a thousand thrills
looks at his rediscovered photographs
many never in print before portraits of
jazz legend Miles Davis heiress boria
Vanderbilt actress Grace Kelly
and that's a rough print of jane fonda
one of her first fashion photographs
which Tom took at Vogue this is Mia
Farrow again a first it was when she was
in Peyton Place she was 16 and this is
Jack Kerouac
who Miles Davis had introduced him to
that was the connection yes Columbo shot
advertisements and album covers Johnny
Mathis
the most frequent subject of Palumbo's
lens was an Saint Marie one of the 50s
most glamorous models
she had a mystery about her palumbo said
Saint Marie became the photographer's
muse and wife before Bosworth was it
strange in a way of putting a book
together about in effect your
predecessor no it really wasn't I had no
feeling of jealousy I could never
compete with her she's AB C's drop-dead
gorgeous
was one of the great models of all time
I appreciated and really admired the way
they worked together the way they
collaborated on these amazing shoots
they created fantastic photographs and I
felt that they should be shown born in
the Italian fishing village of mofetta
Tommaso Palumbo came to America when he
was just 12 actually he wanted to be a
painter when he was very young and then
his father gave him a brownie camera and
and he was hooked on on taking
photographs how did you and Tom first me
way in the early 50s I was a model not a
very good model but he took my some of
my first test shots and and I liked him
a lot but of course he was married and I
was otherwise engaged myself you had a
brief thing though we did have a brief
thing but that was very long ago I mean
that have been then we didn't see each
other from night almost 20 years Palumbo
gave up photography to become an
advertising executive Bosworth left
modeling for acting at first appearing
on Broadway and opposite Audrey Hepburn
in the 1959 film the nun story the grand
silence doesn't matter for me I'm not
taking my vows I'm leaving
in 1986 after both lost their spouses to
cancer they ran into each other again on
the street so we decided to have coffee
together and one thing led to another
and we moved in to this very loft what
was your connection with him I wanted to
be around artists I wanted to be around
creative people and tom was was the most
creative person I'd ever met the most
curious they became collaborators on
magazine articles theater projects and
finally this book it's always
interesting when you lay out a body of
work hmm you know what you see yes I
think I was able to really show the
evolution of an artist this book is a
10-year labor of love their fanciful
pictures they're dreamy pictures they're
gorgeous pictures yeah they're really
remarkable pictures it's and it's
incredible to me to when you think about
it you know he put down his camera you
know for a long time and yet this
incredible body works you know is still
there I think it's remarkable as well
how Patricia Bosworth kills just look at
this in such an objective way and
appreciate his talent and have
absolutely not a hint of jealousy I mean
personally it's just fascinating to see
that dynamic she really understood is
great it's a great book